مخاوف جمهوريه من تصاعد الهجمات بين ترامب
وديسان تدفع استراتيجي الحزب لتحذير من
خطوره هذه الحرب على مصداقيه الجمهوريين
السباق التمهيدي الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه في الحزب الجمهوري تحول الى
مواجهه مريره بين المرشحين الذين يحتلان
المرتبه الاولى والثانيه في استطلاعات
الراي فالاستطلاع يرجح حصول على 49% من
نوايا تصويت وروند سنتس على 19% رغم ان
تصويت الجمهوريين ما زال يبعد اكثر من سته
اشهر ترامب وديسان
ملامحها في فعاليات انتخابيه في ولايتي
ايوا ونيو فحمله ديسانتس اي حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا كانت ركزت على تصويره مدافعا شرسا
عن القيم الجمهوريه المحافظه في قضايا
تشمل اجهاض والهجره والانفاق الحكومي حتى
الجريمه ويحمل المرشح الذي يبلغ 44 عاما
يحمل ترامب مسؤوليه تتراجع اجنده
المحافظين خاصه خلال السنوات الاربعه التي
قضاها في البيت الابيض في المقابل يرد
ترامب ومساعدوها على تلك الاتهامات بالقول
ان ديسانتس يحتاج الى اكثر من ثماني سنوات
لانجاز ما حققه ترامب مقللين من انجازاته
بصفته حاكمه لفلوريدا حرس ديسانس قبل
اسابيع من اعلان الترشحه رسميا حرص على
تفادي انتقاد ترامب والانخراط في الهجمات
الشخصيه مقدما نفسه ثقلا موازنا ورصيلا
وموضوعيا لرئيس السابق
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات